&gt;&gt; We know that either this factor, x minus 4, or this factor, x plus 3, have to
equal 0 in order to make this entire expression equal to 0. That means the
answers for either one of these equations will satisfy this one. So our two
numbers that x can equal then to satisfy this equation are 4 and negative 3.
Let's look at a graph of this real quick. To help you visualize this a little
bit better, here's the graph of the parabola corresponding to our original
equation, which you'll recall was y equals x minus 4 times x plus 3. It's really
easy to mistake this equation that we're solving with the equation for the
parabola. But please remember that this is the equation we get when we plug in a
certain y value. This does not relate x to y, and therefore it can't graph all
these different points. Looking at the full problem, we can however notice the
value of what we found. Here's the point, negative 3, 0, one of our
x-intercepts, which we found right here, and here's the other one, 4, 0. Please
remember that x-intercepts are actually points, because what we're solving for
here are the x-coordinates of those points.